one million subscribers a youtube
milestone i never expected to reach but
here's the story of how i got here in
2017 i started the channel with no video
editing skills and zero expectations i
hated the sound of my own voice and have
been told i have the personality of a
carrot but i was like screw it i'm going
to try youtube and probably fail and
disappoint my mom again in the process i
found there was a need for developer
content around angular and firebase so i
created some really bad videos that were
very useful to this highly specialized
audience welcome to angularfirebase you
create a new app with the angular cli
then these files are going to be here by
default i even remember my very first
comment that motivated me to keep
pushing forward in the early game the
key is to find a specialized unmet need
in the market then create the useful
educational content that audience is
looking for if you're consistent
uploading a new video say once a week
that should take you to about 10 000
subscribers in about a year or so but
then you'll hit a ceiling by the mid
game my video editing skills were much
improved to grow further i created
videos targeted at a wider audience my
first real banger was firebase basics my
philosophy has always been to make the
next video better than the last one it
takes a lot of time and experimentation
to really optimize the content for what
your audience is looking for listen to
feedback and give the audience what they
want like i don't show my face in my
videos because my handsomeness is
distracting and it forces me to find
useful graphics that actually represent
what i'm talking about what you don't
want to do is copy somebody else not
only will that eat away at your soul but
in order to grow on youtube you really
need to find the thing that makes you
unique to reach 100k subscribers it took
675 days and 150 uploads the late game
is where things get difficult you'll be
extremely burned out at this point and
10xing the road to 100k might seem
impossible to keep growing though the
formula is simple keep uploading and
keep getting better at this point i
started taking a more scientific
approach by optimizing two metrics the
click-through rating and the watch time
to optimize clicks you need a good title
and thumbnail that's more of an art form
than anything you need to know what your
audience wants and how to surprise them
with something creative for me that
comes easy because i also have a lot of
fun and get really excited about every
video i create for watch time i have a
formula with three ingredients most
importantly the content needs to be
educational and useful the second
ingredient is storytelling there are so
many interesting stories to tell about
the history of software and the people
behind it the final ingredient is humor
i can tell jokes that are actually
encoded messages of things that i
couldn't say otherwise without sounding
like a total dick this has been how to
get 1 million youtube subscribers in 100
seconds and i want to send a huge thank
you to everybody who supported my
channel over the years it truly means
more to me than you'll ever know i've
learned so much met amazing people and
have the rare privilege of actually
enjoying what i do for work and now we
get to start down the road to 10 million
i'm not sure how we'll get there yet but
we will get there or die trying thanks
for watching and i will see you in the
next one
[Music]